good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Thursday I am in such a
glorious mood wowow to what do we owe
the pleasure well so many things one my
move is done so that's stress is off my
plate two I'm a naturally happy person
so when I don't have something like so
harrowing and stressful I'm my gorgeous
glorious delightful self but you said
you wouldn't be able to be happy until
this evening what's up your
timetable um well the home organizers
with a good Constitution done and done
they are at my place doing all the
unpacking and organizing so like what's
better than things like being taken care
of I agree and I'm with my girl jack and
I'm just feeling good I'm so happy for
this change of tune really I also hate
like when I come on an episode and I'm
not able to like get past my own
whatever [__] like sometimes that
happens where you're just in a mood and
it feels like I can't properly like do
my job and every single day like I have
a million things to do but the one thing
I always have to do is you know be
myself on the toast and so when my
personal angst starts to affect that I I
get mad at myself when it starts to
Cloud yeah Claudia you were a Claudia
yesterday but I came out of it and when
I was done I felt so much better first
you were a storm cloudia all right don't
put me in another bad mood I'm doing my
best what's a what's a what's a nice
Cloud you know a nice puffy White Cloud
a summer's day you're a summer's day
you're a summer's day
thanks um so I vlogged the whole
experience right it is already on
patreon I was like let me get the
girlies what they need and the Vlog
takes like kind of a crazy turn at one
point um and I wanted to talk about this
on the toast because the more I talk
about it the more I get people's
experience and feedback and the better I
feel
so during the Vlog Theo was staying with
Ben's parents because moving is just
like stressful and there was like
nowhere for Theo to hang out and Theo's
been like acting a little weird he
appears to have like a leg that's
hurting him and we thought it would go
away and then it didn't so Ben's mom was
so generous and was like while I have
him I'll take him to the vet for you
like oh my God Queen because you know my
ass was like never taking him and every
time Theo goes to the vet he gets like a
checkup of course but because he's a
King Charles cavalier and they're as a
breed predisposed to heart problems they
always do like an extra you know checkup
on his and every time we go they say no
heart murmur and we're like great great
great this time of course busy season we
weren't even thinking about the heart he
at the age of six has developed a heart
murmur and this is something I'm lit
going to cry but I'm really going to try
not to this is something you know we
grew up with a Cavalier we know that
this is a part of their life and that's
why we're so crazy about keeping them
fit and healthy so it's always been top
of mind I knew this was something we
were going to have to deal with at some
point you know my delusional dream I
thought it would be 30 years down the
road
um it's a grade two out of five which is
moderate and what that means is that
either it stays a two he goes on meds
lives with it not a big deal or it's the
beginning of like heart problems so I
found out while I was in the movie in
the midst of vlogging and moving and I
didn't know if I should like include it
in the Vlog and I like recorded
something and I felt so stupid like
being so upset and recording something
but I don't know I was like alone and I
didn't have anyone to talk to and I was
like in the whole day every 10 minutes
updating the Vlog about what was going
on and like this was what was going on
so it wasn't sure if I was going to
include it and I ended up including it
and I'm so glad that I did because so
many people reached out to me who have
Cavaliers but who also just have dogs
and was like oh my God we found out our
dog had a heart murmur like same
experience wanted to die and he's lived
with it completely fine the told me
stories of their dogs who lived to be 14
and then I spoke to my friend Shannon
yesterday not Ford but my friend Shannon
from La who is like a dog professional
like she has probably a hundred dogs
she's like a Foster and she's like oh
please I had a dog who showed up at my
house 12 years old they told me he was
going to live for another day and he
lived four more years like a heart
murmur you can live with so I feel
actually really glad that I shared it
because so many people shared their
positive experiences um but that was
kind of a a turning point in the Vlog
yeah I would say so and I think that's
also contributed to your mood yesterday
I know you weren't talking about on the
show yesterday but you were uh you know
rightfully torn up about it but I know
our boy is fierce our boy is strong this
Dr sand I'm looking at my um SEO pillow
over there wishing I had wishing I had
it here to give him a hug you know yeah
I think that um you know they go on meds
and then twice a year you take him to a
Cardiologist and it should
be okay unless he has some crazy and
this is just like the beginning he goes
a grade 2 3 four five like hopefully
that's not the case I was prepared for
news like this in my lifetime like I
knew that this was coming I just wasn't
prepared for it to happen on like this
crazy busy day where I'm moving and he
was going to the bed for something else
yeah that's bad bad news waits for
nobody we're with you and whatever you
need whatever Theo needs he obviously
gets his health insurance through the
toast so we'll provide whatever he needs
thank you for being like my employer has
been really amazing throughout this
whole situation that's really like all
you can hope for no it's true and like
let's talk about employers that are
not like gracious and flexible when
something like actually happens to a
person I don't know if people talk about
that like when you work in a corporate
job they have like weird weird rules
like family member death oh was it
immediate family oh if not you get EX
like it's so weird like people are
people do they have that I I've never
thought about it yes cuz uh someone I
know just lost someone in their
immediate family I'm like well what are
you doing about work and she was telling
me that they have like you know well if
it's immediate family you get X if it's
a grand like you get ex but like some
people's grandparents are their mothers
you know right so I think that's like a
weird thing not enough people talk about
like grief when it comes to like of
course we're always talking about
parental and etal leave which is so
important so important we should still
keep having those conversations but like
what about grief grief leave grief
leave it doesn't sound right it doesn't
well we need to come up with another
word for it I guess it's like personal
time no I think like maybe grievance
leave it's just like grief Leaf is weird
I got it a leave of grievance a leave of
grievance yeah like a leave of absence
yeah yeah no that sounds really nice
yeah but grief crazy few days grief is
personal you know that's true some
people like want to go back to work
almost immediately and then six months
time like have a breakdown because they
didn't properly grieve so maybe they
need that leave of grieve in in six
months yeah but I understand like the
corporation's trying to put together
some sort of framework you know like but
they could do better yeah yeah you just
got to they could do better in
everything everyone could do better I
think uh what could I do aside from us
of
course what can I do better
Jack curbing my moods no because I think
that's just the E and flow of life
you're still human I still want you to
be human no no because I like it you
look absolutely gorgeous and radiant
today did you do something different
with your F what are you referring to no
your skin is glowy you look like almost
maybe like you stepped into the Sun for
30 seconds no still
homebound if anything last week I was in
the sun more cuz I was walking more this
week I'm not walking so much cuz I
twisted my
ankle can we tell every R oh my God this
is the funniest story Jackie Twisted her
ankle which like I feel like adults
don't do it's I don't think I feel like
sober people don't do like the feeling
that I have in my ankle right now like
I'm having flashbacks to college I feel
like there was a I took a couple nasty
spills like in high Jeffrey Campbell
heels and like my ankle was twisted for
months it felt this way so tell everyone
the story about this weekend when you
twisted your ankle so this weekend I I
twisted my ankle being a [__] and it's
just like completely my fault and like
it's something that I look back I'm like
oh my God like like I feel red in the
face of how stupid I was we Jackie it
sounds like you need toden yourself yeah
I but I feel like I did in my personal
life but I guess on the show so we were
having a family outing and we were
parked somewhere and like we there was a
really long way around to get onto the
sidewalk I also didn't feel like that
route was the safest cuz it was like
there was cars and everything but we
could just like cross over the grass to
get to the sidewalk much quicker and
other people cut a cut through and other
people were cutting through the grass
cuz I thought that maybe it's like
swampy no or ticks or ticks but other
people were cutting through so I was
like let's just cut through and it was
much like deeper than I anticipated and
I twisted my ankle and it was so painful
I couldn't even go on I had to walk back
to the car and I sat in the car with
Charlie the whole time and Zach while
the family outing yeah well Zach and
Harry went on the outing we like waited
in the car for an hour until they were
done like I I literally couldn't move
I'm so sorry about your ankle nothing
takes a girl out like a sprained ankle
so so I had an Ace bandage which really
helped I've been wearing that the last
few days and my ankle was feeling better
but I slept on it badly last night and
now this morning it's hurting again I I
don't actually understand the science
behind an Ace bandage like how does
wrapping it up help like compressing it
so it can't you know fester and sort of
fall apart I guess like kind of like
putting it back together pushing it
inward yeah cuz you got to wrap it real
tight real tight like the swollenness
you got to push it in it really honestly
the ace bandage really did help and I
blame strand for today's pain he took up
the whole bed last night I like so my
ankle was just like it went wherever it
could yeah I understand but I still love
you
strand I love you
strand Yes I Do by the way we have an
amazing show today uh yesterday we did
not do deer toasters and we're still not
doing it today because when we thought
all right we have to do deer toasters
should we do Thursday or Friday Friday's
episodes always feel like a little like
lacking substance cuz nothing ever
happens on a Friday so now we have
Friday your toasters which is fabulous
yeah and I guess we could do a little TV
recap today because real house of
Beverly Hills was on I didn't finish it
because Charlie needed um a a quiet calm
environment and like I had to turn the
TV off I didn't even want to but I had
to he needed a quiet woman yeah and he
needed Eagle woman and you weren't there
yeah so we'll do real house Beverly
Hills recap I watch it and I also watch
watch Happens Live which I have I mean
real house of Beverly Hills was so
boring I don't know what we could
possibly recap but watch Robin live was
full of inant facts Okay cool so we'll
recap that we've got the fast five
stories and I think without further Ado
we should get into it because I know
tur's got a busy day I've got a busy day
I'm doing another podcast after this
who's um it's
called what's wrong with me I literally
know what it's called it's called what's
wrong with me that's actually a good
name for a podcast that is a good name
for a podcast no honestly maybe Jackie
don't say it now because it's like I
know I know what it is cuz why CU now
it's like rude I didn't know yeah don't
say it
but I know what it is and I'm actually
really excited I don't do podcast other
podcasts that often I'm very like choosy
because you know it's a lot to have an
hourlong conversation with someone it
could be so awkward but these girls seem
great I'm excited to CH chat I am also
doing some content after this who
remembers last year when I met Mark
shown wer the love of my life who was a
holocaust who was a holocaust Survivor
we did uh like a Hanukkah video series
that's how we met we were paired up and
because we connected so fiercely last
year we're doing it again this year I
actually spoke to him last week we did a
zoom call um and this year's is actually
really funny because Mark has been
cooking all week his like favorite
Jewish Eastern European dishes and I'm
going to have to try them do you know
what he's making I do know what he's
making I don't want to spoil it I also
don't remember like the entire menu list
they asked me like to approve certain
things like there are certain things I
will just won't eat like a crep like I'm
not eating that I actually think you'll
like some of it cuz like probably some
of it stuff that we grew up with like is
he going to make a cabbage soup no he's
not going to make a cabbage soup he's
making a few like of his Cornerstone
items I'm not going to spoil it but that
video will be up soon I just any day I
get to spend with Mark a dream I told
tury this but for Shabbat this week I'm
making something I've never made before
that I'm so excited I don't know why I'm
like craving it no listen go off just
because I think it's I don't even know
if I've ever had it me neither by the
way in my life but I saw a reel a
cooking reel of it and what I'm making
is beef stew now is it
chant similar CH beef stew chili beef
stew are all very similar so it's like a
I don't know it's like beef cooked in
like a tomato soup sort of thing oh
tomato I do believe so Chillin is like a
classic Jewish dish it's really like a
beef stew but it's really chunky this is
like meat chunks and broth and potato
has like oh that's literally chilling
it's not Chillin no potatoes carrots
beef in like a stew that's chilling it's
a stew a beef
stew also known as chillin the Sue of
our people they were making Chillin in
uh Shadle shettle thank you I couldn't
think of the word well I'm going to make
a beef stew cuz I saw it on a real so
first I wanted to copy the real recipe
but the creator doesn't have like a
recipe website so I'd have to like keep
reading the caption which no no so I
Googled beef stew recipe but I also
wanted to put it to the people anyone
know of a great beef stew recipe do you
want me to check my J Cohen cookbook you
could check it I trust him now yeah me
too that I'm actually the first like
real meal me and Ben are going to make
maybe not this Friday cuz like we're
still a little chaotic maybe next Friday
for Shabbat I want to make the
brisket I really also want to make the
brisket again and also why I want to
make beef stew it's like something
hearty and warm like that will be really
good for my milk
supply oh they were on to something in
that shutle they were on to something
cuz a few weeks ago my friend Sam had a
baby right around when I did and we were
like comparing you know pumping amounts
and she was like oh my God I got so much
this morning I had beef stew last night
I was like like they say like warm food
is really good like liquidy food so oh
you got to make the brisket too I want
to make the brisket maybe I'll wait till
you're back I'm going to sit and e a
whole brisket by myself and if you don't
know what brisket we're talking about
you have to become a patreon member
there are two back to backto back Vlogs
for rashash Shana this year Olivia made
a brisket Jackie made a brisket Jackie
and I like followed this recipe from a
cookbook I had just got in PR from Jake
Cohen the Tik tocker and honestly it was
the craziest thing ever but it ended up
being the most insanely delicious
amazing thing so between the moving Vlog
the brisket it's never a bad time to
become a patreon member
patreon.com thee toast yeah good stuff
over there we've got two more episodes
coming at you this month and they are
good ones podcast episodes for the
podcast listeners yeah we had a lot of
Vlogs this month my Jackie's uh
children's book Vlog for launch week oh
wait we didn't even talk about how like
we're
stars on Entertainment Tonight yeah so
last week last week was such a crazy
week because Jackie was here for her
book and then everything was happening
in Israel and like we like literally
didn't know how to function that was two
weeks ago you were in La last week oh my
God
so o uh and Entertainment Tonight We had
scheduled for them to come to interview
US do like a studio tour talk about
Jackie's book just talk about the toast
and it was so good it just came out on
digital I think it airs this weekend if
you go to Entertainment Tonight you
should be able to find it we talk about
everything the book how we started the
toast our favorite guests our least
favorite guest OIC of course I can't
leave my house without talking about it
and actually the first thing in my
apartment was OIC the first thing before
any of the boxes get right in the fridge
right in the fridge
priorities yeah well if that thing drops
in temperature I'm screwed no the
Entertainment Tonight segment was so
good it was fun and there's just like
kind of a lot of behind the scen stuff
about your girls that you might not know
I feel like everyone knows everything
about us but they found like a new Fresh
angle to keep it fresh 100% so check
that out 100% certified
fresh what's that Rotten Tomatoes okay
that's what I thought when something's
good they call it certified fresh I
don't really like to talk about Rotten
Tomatoes or give them any sort of
credence cuz I think the entire
philosophy the philosophy of their brand
is broken and flawed no there are broken
people I mean that's never been more
clear it's so rigged and fraudulent and
they act as if they're the voice of the
people and they're the voice of nobody
they speak for nobody except for maybe
like a couple kagin
critics
Kagan
critics couldn't have said it better
myself so now without further due to do
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by rackin very
exciting just lost my very exciting my
tab okay today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by rettin where you can
shop for everything from Fashion to
beauty and Home Decor to groceries
rettin makes it so easy to earn cash
back when you shop a thousands of Brands
across almost every category and with
holiday shopping around the corner
rettin is the smartest way to money when
you shop because you can stack holiday
sales and Deals on top of cash back to
maximize your savings some of our
favorite Brands like Elf Cosmetics Dyson
Stanley are all participating in rakon's
Cyber Monday and Black Friday deals and
during Black Friday to Cyber Monday are
the highest cash back rates of the Year
all the way up to 15% cash back on the
stores you are already shopping Black
Friday and Cyber Monday can be
overwhelming but with rettin they are
making it easy to earn cash back and get
all your holiday shopping done start all
your shopping trips at rettin
or get the rettin app to start saving
today your cash back really adds up with
all the money we're spending in the next
few months because of the holidays
Hanukah Christmas K Quanza like you
better be doing the most to earn cash
back to be maximizing deals and just
taking advantage of all that and Rakin
is the number one place to start they
will help you out and they also have
just fabulous Brands like Dyson hello
hello so shop at ron.com or get the
rakitin app it's r a k uen that's the
app to start saving today your cash back
really does add up today's episode is
also brought to
you by saxs we are always doing our best
when it comes to looking fabulous on the
podcast oh my God you know we used to
say we're maxinista we're sax andas
we're sax anas I love that so sometimes
our pajama uniforms and sweatshirts do
need a little bit of an upgrade and
that's why we love shopping at sax.com
for everything from podcast looks to gno
outfits and more it's also just easy to
shop on the saxs website they have so
many different categories you can go
specific like when I go on vacation I
always do like a haul and they have a
vacation edit they have um work edit
wedding guest they just make it really
easy to find exactly what you're looking
for because they have pages and pages of
really beautiful things but their
categories make it really easy to shop
um so whether you're going for a cozy
Vibe you can shop that a more elevated
look they've got it all at sax.com and
those categories I was talking about
they get really specific like if you
want to shop by your star sign cuz you
know I am like a cancer Moon Leo Rising
I don't know if you knew that about me
somebody told me that in the comments
yesterday I could shop that way if I
wanted to you could find the perfect
Revenge dress from Brands like
Christopher esber and cult Gia another
great reason to shop at Sachs is because
they do such a great job of discovering
new upand cominging designers and you
can start wear wearing certain Tings
before everyone else like the outfit I
wore to the ARs tour Danielle guio like
found it at sax before everybody else
and now everyone's wearing it and like I
was cool cuz I had it before so discover
new ways to shop for everything every
day at sax.com that's saks.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by drizzly the go-to app for drink
delivery drizzly is the most convenient
way to get beer Wine and Spirits
delivered to your doorstep right when
you want it their tailored experience
lets you find the perfect drink for the
occasion no matter what it is you'll
save big time by shopping a huge
selection of drinks from wherever you
are you'll save money by comparing
prices on drinks across multiple stores
great for gifting like you're headed to
a dinner party and you told your husband
to pick something up and he of course he
didn't but you're leaving in like 2
hours do it on drizzly it'll show and do
all the work for you you can get a nice
bottle of wine it's nice to show up
somewhere with something and drizzly
understands that so the last minute gift
is covered with the option to schedule
ahead ship and deliver gifts on demand
so if like you're on your way out and
you realize you forgot ship directly to
their door saving everyone time also
another fabulous part about drizzly is
that in a lot of cities you can get Aran
cocktail sprit Society on it it's just
fabulous I love
drizzly um so download the drizzly app
don't be stupid or go to drizly.com
that's Dr I
l.com use cod toast and you'll get $5
off or $0 delivery fee off your next
order you must be 20 21 or over it's not
valid in all states codes cannot be
combined with any other offers not valid
at all retailers code expires November
10th 2023 at 11:59 p.m. eastern time
thank you drizzly for sponsoring that
code One More Time download the drizzly
app or go to drizly.com
dr.com use code toast you receive $5 off
or $0 delivery Fe off your next order
must be 21 or over not valid in all
states codes cannot be combined with any
other offers not valid at all retailers
codes expire November 10th 2023 1159
p.m. eastern time thank you Claudia
you're welcome our first story a bit of
podcasting rumor news oh my God is it
about us everyone's always starting
stuff about us no not today not today
not today not
today about a similar star Megan Markle
is is thrilled as she nears a
multi-million dollar make or break deal
for her podcast so Megan marle is
thrilled about being on the verge of
Landing her first major deal since
parting ways with Spotify according to a
new report The Duchess of Sussex how do
they know she's thrilled like right I
mean if you're if you're signing a deal
any deal I imagine you're it's thrilling
it's fair to assume it's fair to assume
but the duchess is said to be inching
closer towards signing on the dotted
line for a multi-million dollar contract
with Amazon's podcast ction partner
Wonder audible oh oh audible cuz
Amazon's podcast like in-house podcast
studio is wondery like they own
smartless yeah but audible is Amazon
yeah but that's audio
books maybe they're combining their
audio department maybe W is under
audible maybe maybe yeah yeah yeah I
like that a source close uh told the
closer UK that the new venture has the
power oh the most legit publication in
all of UK the new venture has the power
to make or break her Hollywood dream
that's a little extreme okay this
article's moronic but what we getting
away taking away is yes her podcast is
not over and that she's talking to
Amazon well that's weird to me because
the narrative with the last podcast was
that they didn't want to do it anymore
and that's why the Spotify deal ended
was that the narrative yeah that like
she didn't fulfill her duties that's
what people were saying and so like they
just ended it before all the episodes
were contractually all the episodes that
she was obligated to do contractually
she hadn't even done them that's what
they said interesting So based on based
on what I know about the Spotify podcast
I would have assumed she wouldn't be
doing a podcast anymore right same but I
mean maybe she liked it maybe now she
knows like how many episodes she wants
to do like maybe now that she has her
feet wet she's prepared to like make a
deal that will work better for her I
feel like that Spotify deal was very
vague now I don't know any but it was
just like a deal and they had their
holiday episode and then she started a
podcast but it wasn't like you're going
to start your Megan marle podcast you're
going to give us 50 episodes a year I
think it was kind of just like L Fair
here you go and then they were upset
that they didn't produce as much as they
had woned but I mean obviously I didn't
see the contract but that's the vibe I
got cuz they let get away with like no
content for years I have to imagine that
the contract said x amount of episodes
like that's just bad
legal
I could just see it being really vague
like because it also like that first
show wasn't even part of archetypes so
it wasn't like she had a contract to do
archetypes right you know what I mean
they just had a contract to have Megan
and Harry on Spotify I mean I could
truly like Wax poetic for hours about
like the
Spotify exclusive podcast business model
that they did for a few years I feel
like they're not doing it anymore they
took a lot of shows um completely
exclusively
but recently they released some of those
shows like armchair expert is now
available on a bunch of platforms I
believe Emma chamberlains is too and
Spotify still like does the distribution
and like ad sales like any random I mean
any ordinary podcast Network would do
for a podcast but they're no longer
exclusive to Spotify call her daddy is
and Joe Rogan is I'm sure there are
others but those are the ones that come
to mind but I don't know like their
business model is like being shaken up
now yeah I think they're in a period of
transition a period of flux I look
forward to seeing how it all plays out
well I'm moving so I totally relate to
being in like a period of transition and
a period of flux and flux and also just
having my
period well this is interesting I when I
saw the headline it was like her make or
break Hollywood dream deal I thought she
might go back to acting okay yeah like
that's so dramatic her make or break if
there was like a make or break Hollywood
dream deal it would have been when she
got on suits so that's over
and second of all like she's already
like A-list permanent no I I would think
a make or break Hollywood dream deal
would be like a thre movie deal with
Martin
scorey yeah or I think what they're
maybe going to end up doing she goes the
route of like ree Witherspoon and does
like because they just did like a book
club optioning uh Emily Henry's book
happy place which I absolutely hated um
they're optioning it into a movie meet
me at the lake oh literally same thing
okay okay same thing meet me at the lake
yes I liked that book a little bit not
uh I didn't hate it um so if she like
started a production company and you
know option 10 books like that's a make
or break Hollywood you become like Reese
right I just I feel like podcasting is
not for her and when I think about like
what I would see her doing it would be
more like Joanna gainy Oprah like
content like we want to see you first of
all it's true you're a gorgeous lady we
want to see you and like we want to see
the F house and we want to see the house
we want to see the V VI es yep yep yep
yep that's so true podcasting is it's
for hiders it's for ugly girls no
kidding I'm completely kidding um I
agree she's far too beautiful to be like
hidden behind the microphone I agree and
it's also and maybe this is was her
experience it sounds like such an easy
job and I think people underestimate the
amount of like labor that's required to
put out like a good piece of content
even if you have help so maybe and I
think that happens to a lot of people
you start a podcast and it's just like
it was supposed to be a side thing but
it's a lot of [__] work and you have
to like Leverage leverage your personal
relationships to ask people to come on
like maybe she didn't want to do that it
just it's not as like dumb and simple as
I think a lot of people think it is and
so maybe that was her experience she was
like you know this is like too much work
I'm over it but she's going back to it
right so that's the surprising piece if
true keep in mind this is not a person
who needs to work like
imminently they have a good amount of
money they have a good amount of money
they would be okay I think think they
will they do like need to work a bit no
they need to sustain the lifestyle to
sustain the lifestyle but I also think
that they want to
be top of Mind relevant like in the
Press spoken about that helps their
other Ventures you know you got to have
something going on that's goes for
anyone that goes for the business that's
Hollywood baby that's Showbiz baby
that's Showbiz um so let's just hope and
cross our fingers it's a
vodcast yeah the Spotify one was not
even though Spotify likes a vodcast
everyone loves a vodcast like you want
to see [__] vodcasting is the new thing
vodcasting greater than podcasting we've
been doing it since day one that's the
thing about us that nobody ever like
gives us credit for for the trailblazing
effect of our business yeah but we know
and that's like all that matters
not not are you ready for our next story
I honestly L and truely am some more
Memoir news this week we've got another
Memoir coming out next week I could give
you I could give you a million guesses
and you won't guess who's WR who wrote
their Memoirs really yeah he's just not
someone you think about okay actually I
guess I could give you some roundabout
Clues maybe you could get it cuz weirdly
when I think of this guy right now like
this is what I think of sadly I know
there are more obvious Clues but this is
what I think
of father of Kim's
friend Lionel Richie no good guess Rick
Hilton no good
guess get father of
lifer father of lifer David Foster
no father of lifer you might not know
this fun fact maybe not Henry
Winkler I knew that and I have a story
about Henry Winkler I don't know I feel
like every time he comes up on the toast
I've said it he's only come up like once
or twice I had a really interesting
interaction with Henry Winkler on a
flight what happened maybe it'll be in
his Memoir no literally cuz it was I I
think he was really taken by me he gets
on the plane and the seat that I was New
York to LA the seat that I was sitting
in was like the seat he needed cuz he
was like with a like his family or
something and he was like do you mind
switching I actually ended up getting a
better seat so I was happy to do it and
when I heard it was for a celebrity I
was more than happy to oblige he was so
grateful like you would have thought I
gave him like the shirt off my back he
was so grateful and like the whole
flight every time he walked by me he was
like oh thank you such a nice guy and we
just kind of became best friends after
that so I look forward to reading about
it from his perspective yeah in his new
Memoir called being Henry the fs and
Beyond yeah he has like a huge Legacy
that I'm so unfamiliar with yeah what is
the fs I have no idea to me a show he's
like the water boy
yeah but to other people he's the fond
and I think being described as Kim's
friend's dad right Zoe right yeah yeah
anyways he has his Memoirs coming out
why do calls of a foni Memoirs of a
Fonzi that would be a better name but
why do when someone's written their
Memoirs why is it plural even though
it's a memoir it's a good question maybe
because it's like their memories in a
book but it makes no sense um what do
you think is the best
titled Memoir besides girl girl with no
job the crazy beautiful life of an
Instagram thirst monster Memoirs of a
Shand no but like for
real uh I would need a list I know you
you what CU I have an answer it was Resa
farahan from Shaws of sunset Memoirs of
a gay sha oh yeah I don't think I've
ever heard a better titled book no I
didn't even hear that honestly like
that's the kind of book where it's like
you you have the title first and then
you write the book to suit the title
100% because I cannot hear the word
Memoir without thinking of that film
Memoirs of AA which I've literally never
seen I don't even know what it's about
you know I it's a book first and I think
it's an amazing book I haven't read it
or seen the movie and I think that's a
book that we should read maybe do it for
the the redheads it's I'm sure someone
in of the four of us has read it but
it's historical fiction oh you know what
I mean like I actually should read that
yeah like Memoirs of a I always am
saying something like that Memoirs of a
something
M oh somebody gave me a good uh my
friend our friend Joe grun he texted me
because he listens to the toast and I
was saying what should my next book be
called A Tale of Two
turties which two of these turties so
he's like you need to have kids and like
then there's like two turties like the
new mom era and then like the previous
wack job turty okay but you really want
tury in the title like no but
yes we'll work on it just it's a
starting point but speaking of his
Memoirs Henry Winkler has written his
and he's opening up about rejecting the
lead role in Greece I love these stories
I love these stories um so it only took
one word spread across three syllables
for Henry Winkler to go down in
television history in his first audition
for Happy Days Winkler dropped his
iconic a which became an immediate
signature for his 1950s Greaser Arthur
Fonzi Fonzerelli I guess that's oh so
it's happy days I guess
so so unfamiliar after his effortlessly
cool character became a Bedrock of the
hit American sitcom across its shows the
word Bedrock Bedrock beans are the
Bedrock right Winkler found himself
paral this is a People magazine article
that's incredibly well
written Winkler found himself Paralyzed
by fears of being typ cast going so far
as to turn down the role of Danny Zuko
in 1978's Greece which was ultimately
played by John Travolta he writes in his
Memoir I need to look up what a young
Henry Winkler looks like just so I can
visualize him as Danny Zuko Henry said I
was dumb I spent so much energy so much
time I spent so many sleepless nights
thinking how do I not get typ cast what
would he tell actors facing a similar
predicament today you go with the flow
what you do is you prepare to reinvent
yourself you do something completely
different and then come back to Center I
feel like the idea of being typ cast
like the the predicament of being typ
cast is such a good problem to have like
such a luxury to be like oh in so many
things as this so many popular things as
the same person like okay if you ever
get to that point like a good problem to
have I just looked up a picture of a
young Henry Winkler um he looks
literally like Danny Zuko his hair is
gelled back and he was wearing a leather
jacket and I guess that might have been
what his character on Happy Days was
like so we didn't want to do another
like slickback bad boy thing so I get it
and you know what it kind of served him
well because my sort of uh Association
of Henry Winkler is like family man
cutie like opposite of Danny Zuko so it
worked yeah I agree and honestly that
movie like made John Travolta after
Saturday night Saturday Night Fever so H
like that was good for John Travolta it
was good for Scientology and I guess
good for Henry Winkler it was meant to
be cuz John Travolta is meant to be
Danny Zuko I'm not looking for a
different Danny Zuko I feel like
whenever we hear about mcasting news
like things that almost it's always from
watch happin live yeah so I'm glad to
have gotten this from another news
source from a primary source from a
primary source I don't know if I would
read this book I don't think that I
would I I would require too much
Googling for me and also it's like I
don't even know how happy days was
received was it the biggest show on TV I
don't know how many seasons it was it
was yeah but like if unless you lived it
or even remote familiar with it I don't
feel like it would be interesting yeah
but then like I read um a memoir last
year by Carrie White she was a celebrity
hair stylist like in the 7s 80s and you
would think like that wouldn't do it for
me but it was so fascinating yeah I
remember it's called uppercut I highly
recommend I like that name that's a good
title oh what's Henry's title being
Henry it's a little basic and then
subtitled the fonds dot dot dot and
Beyond if he had played Buzz Lightyear
that would be like
better did he who plays Buzz
Lightyear I'm trying to think I know Tom
Hanks is Woody uhhuh who plays Buzz
Lightyear like Voice Tim Allen
classic yeah classic
voice um well happy for the fs happy for
my former seatmate and like it's so good
to see him out here like you know doing
big things why is it
season that's a good question well a lot
of books do come out before holiday
season October November because that's
just good for Book Sales yeah so I think
I do believe that's why another Memoir
that's really amazing is the camper and
the counselor yeah a young girl struggle
it's beautiful to find herself in a
whole new world it's kind of a Coming of
Age story it is a Coming of Age story
and I've got a lot of feedback from
people who it's like this is a great
book not even about Camp just about like
separation anxiety about leaving your
parents for the first time to do
anything like a sleepover it needs that
book it has Eternal lessons yeah it's a
universal story it is it really is are
you ready for our next story yeah Daniel
Radcliffe's Harry Potter stunt double
was paralyzed after deathly hollow set
accident and now the two have teamed up
for a documentary to tell his story so
Daniel Radcliffe has boarded the
upcoming HBO original documentary called
David Holmes The Boy Who Lived as as an
executive producer in addition to being
prominently featured in the film as an
interview subject the movie which is set
to debut in November Chronicles the life
of Daniel's Harry Potter stunt double
who work closely alongside Daniel from
sorcerer Stone all the way to Deathly
Hollows Part One when he was tragically
paralyzed during a set accident Holmes
broke his neck performing a stun and was
paralyzed from the chest down the
official Doc synopsis from HBO reads the
film is a Coming of Age story of
stuntman David Holmes a prodigious
teenage gymnast from Essex England who
was selected to play Daniel rag clip
stunt double in the first Harry Potter
film when Daniel is just 11 over the
next 10 years the two form an
inextricable Bond but on the penultimate
film a tragic accident on set leaves
David paralyzed with a debilitating
spinal injury turning his world upside
down as Daniel and his closest stunt
colleagues rally to support David and
his family in their moment of need it is
David's extraordinary Spirit of
resilience that becomes their greatest
source of strength and inspiration oh my
God I literally have chills yeah I chose
this story I just want to get credit for
it um because I saw it and I was like
this is so fabulous you know telling a
story that would never get told feel
like situations like this get buried
because like Hollywood doesn't
want like
their practices to be called into
question yeah um I love that Daniel
Radcliffe is associated with it one
because it'll just get more eyeballs on
it because that's how the world works
and two I think if he wasn't on it
depending on how the story is told like
he could come off almost like a villain
I don't know what happened but the fact
that he's a part of it and amplifying
the story and you know he has a
friendship with this guy I think it's
fabulous yeah I think it'll be really
interesting I didn't even know this
story I'm not a Harry Potter swirly uh
so maybe it's known in that
Community but I also feel like there are
probably a lot of stories like this that
don't get told like this I would do I
would watch a documentary on like stunt
community in general stunt culture yeah
I mean it's definitely a crazy job to
choose it's for that thrill seeking type
of guy or gal yeah I it's like the
that's a job I could never do I'm like
afraid of [__] everything yeah I
actually saw a video recently you know
how everyone says like Tom Cruz does his
own stunts like that just never meant
anything to me I saw the video too I
think I might have sent it to because I
was so impressed by like what it meant
for him to do his own stuns you probably
sent it to me on reals after I'd seen it
a few times on Tik Tok no you sounded
impressed and it was just like him
riding a motorcycle off a cliff over and
over and over again yeah I agreed like
Tom Cruz does his own stunts like those
are words that meant nothing to me yeah
just a couple of words shung together
especially because I never saw a mission
impossible like I don't know what the
stunts are you know right but I agree I
saw the visual of that and also him
there's a scene where a plane is taking
off and he's like literally holding on
to the plane on the on the wing oh my
God yeah so I saw that too he's a
nut there's literally no reason for that
like in this day age like do it in a
studio and get a computer like I Tom
Cruz is so interesting and you know what
made me think about him the perfect word
for him is nutty like he's nutty but I
was just thinking about him because in
Beckham like when the beckhams move to
America they become friends with
celebrities but they keep saying Tom
Cruz Tom Cruz Tom Cruz like did they I
don't even remember yeah like he was
always out with Tom Cruz like as if that
was like the biggest guy in the world
and like I guess that he is was no he's
not he was like back in the day cuz now
um with the internet like people know
things about Tom Cruz like Scientology
and I think a lot of that came out after
he divorced Katie Holmes yeah Katie
Holmes was like who they were double
dating with at the time but like even
every time Tom Cruz comes out with a
movie it's it's number one he's like the
biggest movie star still but he's he
kind of that definition of like an old
school movie star we don't really have
like movie stars anymore cuz everyone
does a million movies on all the street
streaming but back in the day there was
a couple movies a year that were the
biggest ones and if there was a Tom Cruz
movie like he was the star like he was
the definition of a quintessential movie
star but I one he still is and two it's
just like it doesn't compute for me just
like Tom Cruz does his own stunts like
Tom Cruz new movie like I just I'm not
paying attention it's not our genre so
it was just crazy like it's David
Beckham he's coming to America and it's
about Tom Cruz so who do you think is
like the next Tom Cruz where it's like
every movie
is a sucess Miles Teller I feel like Top
Gun was like the actual passing passing
yeah but I feel like mil teller will do
and has done like more like artsy
introspective movies where it's like Tom
Cruz's action yeah yeah no like Mass
Appeal there's just action movies good
or bad Mission Impossible like mil like
Tom Cruz doesn't get Tom Cruz doesn't
get nominated for an Oscar so I guess
it's like Marvel maybe like Chris
Hemsworth or Chris Pratt Chris Chris
Pratt Pratt of the Chris variety but no
Chris Pratt being a movie isn't a
guaranteed box office success it kind of
is no it's really not why what what
recently even like his super mar Super
Mario huge really got BR every record
yeah they people didn't like it because
they don't like him but it broke every
record that's literally Tom Cruz I stand
by like a a Chris
Hemsworth I think it's a Chris of the
Pratt variety
yeah you're right it's not like the
Oscar artsy like good movies Jurassic
world yeah Jurassic world yeah yeah yeah
he's got a lot of franchises under his
belt Guardians of the Galaxy yeah yeah
yeah no Claudia these two people are the
same but I don't think of Chris Pratt as
like so famous as a person do you know
what I mean I like I don't think he gets
hounded by
Paparazzi you know I think that if he
wanted to he could yeah maybe Tom Cruz
wanted to yeah but now he doesn't
no no
no highway to the danger
zone you know I do know anyways the
documentary on the stunt double looks
FAS oh yeah we took that really far um
it does look fascinating and it makes me
really like Daniel Radcliffe like
amplifying you know the silenced voice
of this person yeah Daniel Radcliffe
another one let's talk about it let's
cuz I've been dying to talk about it for
a [__] minute what do you have to say
I don't know I don't know either what an
interesting fella you think he's set for
life financially 1,000% and that's kind
of the dream I know he does like other
smaller projects now and like he does
like Independence yeah and like comedy
kind of can like [__] around and do
whatever he wants I feel like he's done
like some projects with funny or die
yeah he has this show that's like a
medieval parody show Okay um but yeah he
just can [__] around he has mailbox
money for life love that you think Ron
Weasley does yeah and Emma yeah but she
continues to work like in mainstream
things yeah but she also chooses like
some dogs yeah yeah yes some dogs yeah
for sure like she chooses unprofitable
things not not Beauty And The Bees not
Beauty And The Bees but I feel like I
don't know why I feel like she didn't
want to do
it I'm also so glad you talk about that
cuz I've been dying to talk about it for
[__] minute and I feel like maybe H
Beauty and the Beast is my absolute
favorite recent Disney film in like the
last 20 years it's the best one hands
down it's unreal it's Perfection it's
Perfection we've watched it a thousand
times we know everything about it we
watch like the DVD extras and you're
right like Emma Watson has this a this
attitude where she's like clearly doing
it for the money and she thinks this is
stupid no I don't even think it's for
the money like maybe she was blackmailed
or something but you just get the sense
that she doesn't want to be there and if
you watch the movie now through that
lens you will understand what we're
saying and I think it's because she's
fiercely feminist and Disney at its like
you know Basics especially that film you
know she marries her captor like it's
not the most woke you know female first
herstory type of film but that's why we
love it right so it's like why did she
take it and even when she like when she
would do interviews about the rle she
was like I really wanted Belle to be
like you know um more of an
industrialist industrial Modern Woman
Like You Know take care of herself
independent so that's why they have that
scene of her doing her laundry in an
Innovative way no and that's why um I
also saw this in a um in a DVD extra
something that was Emma Watson's idea
was to have Belle's like dress that she
wears throughout town be hiked up on the
side a signal that she's an
industrialist because she can't be
walking around town in a dress her dress
needs to be hiked up with her boots so
that she can you know do her laundry in
an Innovative way
yeah so she does her laundry an
Innovative way thus you know flipping on
its head the message of Stockholm
syndrome she's very mechanical that she
learned from her father and I'm just
like so why'd you do it yeah like let's
get a woman in here who doesn't care
like because it just kind of puts This
Cloud over the movie of like Emma Watson
hates this movie oh my God you're so
right and like we know Emma Watson we
know her personality and her values and
what she stands for we know honestly
like Belle is different like Belle's not
like that no Belle is just a traditional
woman who likes to read yeah and like
wants to be taken care of you know yeah
she saw that castle she got ideas she
was impressed she had ideas so you're
right I guess like the one fatal flaw is
that Emma Watson's like personality
really doesn't align with the character
of Belle and she doesn't do a good job
of hiding it yeah yeah like Emma Watson
is just one of those girls and I feel
like I'm I always talk about them like
this new modern way feminism who like
wears t-shirts that say you know the
future is is hers her story the future
is female it's very like performative in
my opinion like white woman's activism
and doesn't actually move the needle and
those people like don't actually support
women um this is like my that's just my
I don't know if that's true about Emma
Watson that's just how I receive it that
that sort of activism and it doesn't
align with like the Disney of your no it
doesn't she tried to like make it
something that it's not okay Belle did
her laundry cool right skirt was hiked
up a little bit cool like not in a
provocative way in an industrial way no
and in like a signaling way so that you
oh yeah and then wait like you
eight-year-old viewer know she's not
like other girls and then there's that
scene where her dad is you know being
crazy Maurice and he's putting together
some piece of technology with gears and
ships and he can't figure it out and in
two seconds Belle comes over and she's
like Father she flips the little gear
flips the switch now it works
she's brilliant that Bell she's
brilliant that
Bell so Dango Radcliff doesn't have to
work right that's where that's what we
were going for and until I experienc
Harry Potter which I do believe like as
a boy Mom that's in my future 100% so
that's why like I'm not going to clown
on Harry Potter I just like kind of take
a step back and I'm like I don't know
anything but I look forward to entering
the world because I think once I do I'll
be obsessed and also ever since someone
told me that I'm a Ravenclaw and
explained the traits of Ravenclaw girl
I'm a Ravenclaw I was told I'm a
Gryffindor I think you are a Gryffindor
like you're such a Ravenclaw and I
literally don't even know but I know
they probably read no they're like
independent thinkers like question
everything that's so come to their own
conclusions you Gryffindor is like very
affable is the vibe yeah I'm definitely
a Gryffindor um all I know is that if
somebody calls you a Slytherin like they
hate you and they think you they think
of you like an extremely low but do do
they not hate you more if they call you
Hufflepuff I just think like and maybe I
I have a lack of knowledge I just feel
like if you call me Hufflepuff like
you're calling me fat
1,000%
1,000% and I don't know but it's just
the vibe yeah like Hufflepuff is like
it's
puff it's chubby and from like the few
moments I have seen of Harry Potter like
I just remember like one huffle buff
character that was chubby
yeah no that's definitely
facts I'll need to look more into it I
can't imagine it's a whole house of
chubby people if I have to imagine like
Hufflepuff it's that from Matilda it's
yeah it's like that more chubby affable
type of person but who's severely
underestimated intellectually if I had
to guess got it and Gryffindor is like
that affable kind of like color War
Captain Vibe main character energy color
War Captain yes yeah Slytherin is like
really smart intellectual who uses their
powers for evil yeah and blonde or if
you're
blonde and yeah of course and I think
Ravenclaw is the opposite of that like
really smart intellectually but you use
your power for good and like you think
critically that's why yeah girl is
Ravenclaw I've seen definitely like
Chamber of Commerce whatever that first
movie is
called chamber of secrets
secrets and I definitely saw the second
one and that's it and I was shocked to
find out actually cuz I never like fully
kept up with it that Robert patson plays
a critical role in a later
film it Twilight wasn't his first
franchise he's done this
before I think I've seen this film
before and I didn't like the ending I've
actually I think I have seen a couple
Harry Potters just cuz like you know at
camp we had to go see a movie Harry
Potter there was obsessed there was one
with a tree a big tree it was spooky
sorcerer Stone
let try and guess the names of the Harry
Potter movies I know Chamber of Commerce
and I know sorcerer Stone I know those
are the first two I also I now know
Deathly Hollows I guess it was part one
and two because we just read this
article that was first two and second
two and there're seven movies there are
the middle three what's also crazy is
that in the UK they're called something
different I believe sorcer stone is
called philosopher stone worst name I
think so like where did I Harry Potter
philosopher stone I feel like one of the
films has the word portal in it
like Harry Potter in the philosopher
stone yeah oh you know I think I saw
that on like a um first edition like
website where you could like
buy Harry Potter books Let's go through
them see if they ring a
bell Chamber of
Commerce Harry Potter the complete
collection on
eBay
sorcerer Stone Chamber of Secrets
prisoner of asan oh classic prisoner of
aaban Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire I'm familiar I'm familiar Harry
Potter and the Order of the Phoenix I
don't know her familiar Harry Potter and
the halfblood prince oh I know him I
know him less how much is Harry Pot
going for it on eBay and and the Deathly
Hollows let's see this one's $50 for
seven bucks yeah 1 to seven it's like
not a bad price no but why would you buy
this on eBay and not
Amazon no it's a good point especially
it's a not like first edition or
anything like if you're trying to it's
like a better price than Amazon yeah I
guess if you're trying to be like
sustainable Trails trills bro trills and
this is definitely a better price than
Amazon like you're getting a deal here I
just assume because it's on eBay it's
going to be like more antique yeah yeah
first edition yeah H so if anybody
wanted the complete set go
ahead now are you ready for our next
story is it our next story that's
brought to you by state firm it is the
State Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price and it comes
with a lot of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlist podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common well
they're a reflection of you we all know
my social media is full of heirs yelling
at New York City dmen to let them in the
club even though I found out yesterday
that that epod that video was a scam
Jackie is very much like in her you know
breastfeeding content
co-sleeping whatever those words are
we're we're different but we're so
similar and insurance is the same way we
require different coverage even though
Jackie and I are so similar Jackie is a
homeowner she lives in a different state
she's a Tesla I'm a renter I live in New
York like we we have different needs and
State Farm understands that that's what
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about it gives you options to help
you personalize your coverage so that
you can protect what you care about most
all at an affordable price just for you
so you can see yourself in more of
everything that you love like a good
neighbor oh my
God like a good neighbor State Farm is
there call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary call go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices varied
by state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time it's all done in one
place and it's all done on your terms so
there's a million reasons why you could
start a website uh one of them being
it's 2023 like what are you doing if you
don't have a website if you're starting
a side business or an e-commerce website
Squarespace it's fabulous starting a
website can be extremely overwhelming
and daunting Squarespace makes it easy
they've got templates it'll make your
website look like a professional did it
but it was really just you in your
basement so again e-commerce is a great
reason to have a website if you're a
photographer a videographer an artist
and you want to showcase your assets
have a portfolio of your work they can
do that too they have flexible templates
you can get started with one of them
with designs for every category and use
case you'll be able to customize your
look update content and add features to
fit your unique needs you can also do
email campaigns where you drive sales
and engage your audience with
Squarespace email campaigns you can
easily collect subscribers on your site
and build connections and repeat
business through regular email updates
in my opinion one of the best parts is
that if you are a seller of something
and you sell online but you want to sell
in person you can sell in person by
connecting a square reader to the
Squarespace app you'll be able to keep
your orders your inventory and your
customer data in sync with your online
store so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
toast thank you la you're welcome our
next story it's that time of year it's
the greatest time of year and it's the
time of year for a lot of things but I
feel like one thing we always talk about
around this time of year is the crown
because it always comes out again in
November yeah
oh I'm excited so the final season part
one comes out November 16th part two
comes out on December 14th I don't know
if that means like there's just two long
episodes or what have you but what part
one of the final season so is it like
five episodes and five episodes 10
episodes and 10 episodes one episode and
then one I don't know lard that's not
the point of the story just because you
have the iPad I thought you like knew
everything no I mean I that's not the
point of the story so they just like Dro
that confusing tidbit which I which I
then had to like relay as if I
understood as an expert but the point of
the story is that the crown Creator
Peter Morgan reveals how Queen
Elizabeth's death changed the show's
ending so Peter Morgan the Mind behind
the crown explained to Variety in the
new interview that he was compelled to
change Direction with with the hit
television show as a result of the
Queen's death he said we'd all been
through the experience of the funeral so
because of how deeply everybody will
have felt that I had to try and find a
way in which the final episode dealt
with the character's death even though
she hadn't died yet so the right cuz
we're saying goodbye to her like forever
right and the show will end in 2005 he
said it was important wow to keep the
cut off to keep it historical not
journalistic so it stops almost 20 days
before present time this last season 20
years yeah 20 days LS this season will
delve into um Prince William navigating
life in the wake of his mother's death
the marriage of Charles and Camila the
early stages of William and and Kate
Middleton's relationship and the
relationship between Diana and doie fet
ahead of their fatal car crash in Paris
no and who just died Muhammad fed right
yeah Dodie died in the car right oh and
then um Muhammad died yeah I guess just
recently like a year ago right right
right I love the actor who plays him I
don't know what Mohammad Fed was like in
real life but he's so [__] funny he's
so affable in the show no I relate to
him like all he cares about is Fame and
he's like I have amounts of money get me
Fame no and not even just Fame get me to
the queen yeah no he had Big Dreams I'll
buy this house for the queen yeah no I'm
obsessed with him um now I love the
crown and I love Royals and I love you
know modern Royals but I feel like the
beauty of the crown for me was learning
so much about a time before I was alive
and the crazy things that happened in
the royal family but also in England and
in the world so I feel like a little
fatigued by modern like the Diana years
I feel like there's been so many
documentaries and films and I feel like
we're always talking about Diana with
Harry and Megan so I'm a little I'm a
little Diana erid fatigued but I'll
still watch it i' love it but I think
I'll probably end up when I rewatch the
whole series in 10 years really
preferring the earlier Seasons yeah and
like the Creator said we're getting into
a territory where it's like the history
hasn't been written it's a little bit
disputed it's a lot of Up For Debate He
Said She Said So I um I think the '90s
portion will continue to be very
interesting especially like how Charles
navigates being with Camila I don't
really know even that all that stuff
about like the phone call and the tampon
I didn't know any of that so to me that
was still like things in which I didn't
know MH I do look forward to seeing the
portrayal of William and Kate just
because that's always fun but but the
best part of the crown is like literally
after the episode Googling and being
like Oh my God this these things really
happen uh princess and getting her toes
sucked on the beach right so but I think
like up until 2005 for me personally so
I would have been 13 like I still wasn't
paying that much attention let alone to
like the royal family I didn't have a
care in the world yeah no that's fair
that's totally fair unless like they
were meeting the Spice Girls then I care
which they were I wonder if the Spice
Girls will be in you know how sometimes
they just like yeah like Jackie Kennedy
was in an episode right random like
celebrities real people who met the
queen yeah so I'm really excited for the
final season of the crown it is still my
dream for the a next Crown to be like a
crown prequel and to be about Queen
Victoria oh I would like that I do feel
like they probably more crowns but just
go back further no I totally love or
different um countries different
countries they could do CC Russia
Austria they could do Russia for days
that's the uh wait don't tell
me romanovs yeah just wait till you get
sucked into the romanovs tury no it's in
my future i' love that for you yeah um
even though there was an episode of the
Crown yes about the romanovs and it it
ended seemed that the romanovs ended
poorly right they all get killed I can't
imagine a worse fate yeah yeah yeah were
they Jewish no oh okay I'm conflating to
historical moments certainly not a
friend to the Jews oh so I don't really
care how their fate on it yeah that's
always like I'm obsessed with Russian
history and all the Zars and then it's
like I'll read about them and it's also
glamorous and interesting and it's like
but then like the way they treated their
Jews is literally we live in America now
right that's where our family hails from
as Russian gires ourselves yeah so um
it's it's hard to you know balance but I
just keep it separate no that's just
whenever you as like a Jewish person or
even like any person who's a conscious
adult who knows about the Holocaust but
especially as a Jewish person when I get
into something historical that's not
like World War II like Downtown Abbey it
starts in 1912 I'm like well what were
these peeps doing in 1939 you know oh
yeah and they never get there in
downtown ABY I think the show's then the
movie and it's like 19 27 is the first
movie right so maybe we're at like 1930
I don't think they'll get there because
it gets dicey but it does you know beg
the question I always think like when we
get there Kora from Downtown Abbey is
Jewish so you know maybe she has a story
to tell no but maybe that's why engaging
in like British history is enjoyable
because they never became Nazis that's
so true so you can root for them they
didn't become Nazis but they experienced
the war the world war they fought Nazis
the whole time right they were good
peeps yeah so you can always read for
them so I'm not worried about you know
what Robert Grandam was doing oh that's
true I guess like kaora is not going to
get taken out of her house by a Nazi
because the Ledger says she was Jewish
right because they never made it over
they protected yeah um and even in
Downtown Abbey Robert Grandam actually
does like mention Hitler once because of
Edith's husband who went to Germany No
Edith's husband oh Michael Michael went
to Germany and disappeared and he would
about the brown shirts and Hitler and
they were like there are these guys they
wear brown shirts and they're mad yeah
you're right you're right so that was
like a little Easter egg so such a good
point um so what was I saying so yes so
the Roman offs and it's like every saw
some were terrible and then you know one
dies and the next one's like what's it
going to be for the Jews right you were
saying um though that the crown should
do other generations and other count
yes other Generations would love other
countries would love really someone
should do something extensive on the
romanovs cuz there's so much there yeah
yeah you're right I feel like I've I've
watched everything that I can there's a
really good documentary on Netflix but
it's not like scripted or anything and I
know there's that one show with elf
Anning that I didn't like please don't
tell me to watch it the grit the great
it's called the grit and it's not good
sorry I watched actually weirdly the
first episode did you like it no she
goes and just gets in the first episode
like married off right shipped off yeah
yeah to marry but it's not good they try
to make it like comedy it's funny please
don't tell me to watch it I've tried
I've tried tried and it should be
something I would love yeah so that's
how bad it is yeah our fifth and final
story is like a little bit of viral news
you know us we love to talk about what
everyone's talking about yeah and
there's a list of places going around
that women refuse to go on a first date
okay so this all started on Tik Tok let
me explain cuz I know you don't know
this woman went viral for making a Tik
Tok in her car about this first date she
was going on and the guy took her to the
Cheesecake Factory and she's like are
you [__] kidding me she was very
funny but it sparked a debate about like
would if someone took you to The
Cheesecake Factory would you be upset so
here's a list of places women refuse to
go on a first date and let's discuss and
really as much as I love the Cheesecake
Factory and I I would love to say like
you know if someone took me there on a
first date that would not be a a deal
breaker if they took me there on a first
date like in a serious
way I I think it it's so hard for like a
blank to make a blanket statement on a
place because first of all where do you
live right where do that's the big
question in a lot of places like the
Cheesecake Factory is the only you know
nice sit down restaurant for Miles so
circumstances socioeconomics like there
are a lot of different factors yeah so
are you answering the question like
broadly or as you yourself
so okay let's set the scene I met this
guy on an app he barely knows me like
it's not someone who knows that I love
the Cheesecake Factory cuz like if Ben
took me there I'd be like [__] yes yeah
he barely knows you you live in New York
City or you live in like a smaller
City I don't know if I live in the city
it makes no sense there's 1,000
restaurants before I get to a Cheesecake
Factory inconvenient yeah it's outside
of the city it's in Jersey City right
right okay let's go through the list one
Cheesecake Factory two I would be okay
with it they serve alcohol it's a like I
really would for real two
Applebees okay it's less nice it's more
of a neighborhood spot there's a lot of
like sports teams you know after school
little leagues that go there maybe not
where was where did we go after
Coachella was that Applebee's Applebee's
it was fantastic yeah but we went at
midnight that's true it was like so it's
was like a lit after like it's like a
drunk munchy place got it three
chilies it's a little pedestrian for a
first state yeah where you're trying to
you
know wine and dine but again like it
just depends on the person like living
in New York you have elevated dining so
of course a chain like Chili's isn't
considered fine dining it's not
considered fancy but in different parts
of the country like I just feel like
this conversation isn't fair yeah it's
like in Glee when they go to bread scks
exactly like by the way
perfect example the next one I actually
think is a hard note no matter what and
that's
Chipotle it's a hard note no matter what
even though they do serve beer and some
wi some alcohol but like that is just
not a romantic Vibe even no and a lot of
their seating is bar stool high tops
with no backs that be comfortable even
like Olive Garden which is the next one
like that could be more romantic agreed
Olive Garden's okay six the movies
agreed no matter who you are where
you're from yeah first date because
you're supposed to get to know someone
not sit in silence for 3 hours right
seven your house agreed first agreed
agreed as in yes or no as in a no no
yeah no no you don't go to someone's
house on the first date in this climate
that and also like take me out yeah yeah
n i mean eight any fast food chain yeah
nine Buffalo Wild Wings I don't know
it's like a cute sports bar like it's a
Vibe I think it's okay okay I think it's
okay too 10 Wing Stop I've never been
very similar to Buffalo Wild Wings like
sports bar energy I think it's fine 11
Red
Lobster totally fine I agree it's
elevated fine dining 12 a
buffet the Golden Corral I agree yeah no
that's not the vibe no it's not romantic
and you really can't load up like you
would want to it's so true it's like a
waste of money to pay for the cuz you
can't like you know throw dinner rolls
in your purse yeah 13
IHOP only because it's breakfast
breakfast is not date date is like you
know low the lighting is lowered it's a
little bright in there do they serve
alcohol even no yeah I think you have to
have a liquor license I agree 14 Denny's
same thing yep 15 the gym duh oh I
didn't even know that was up for debate
no 16 interesting church say it was
Temple um I think if that's your
lifestyle that's actually incredibly
sweet I agree as long as we're going to
get a bite to eat after no and as long
as we're on equal Playing Fields like if
this person's really you know very
religious and the person you know going
out on the date is not like don't take
me to your church if I don't like pray
or if I don't ever go but if these are
two churchgoing peeps that's lovely yeah
but we do have to get a B cheat after
it's un undebatable cuz technically it's
in like going to the movies
like yes but it's a little bit different
because you're connecting on a spiritual
level yeah you're not talking you're
getting to know each other it's a it's
different than the movies but it's
similar yeah 17 Starbucks agreed no 18
coffee dates agreed like that's not a
romantic date and certainly not a first
date actually I don't know people do
like coffee dates it's like a quick way
like let's see if we even like connect
on the smallest level and then we'll
take it out for real it's like kind of a
good I agree but that's like what going
for a drink is for and I just feel like
coffee if you're really in a place where
like you're just like grabbing coffee to
see if you're even like this person like
you must be going on so many dates like
it should be a little special thing it
should be special it becomes a little
kind of um and coffe is like you can't
drink coffee past 5:00 so like we're
just meeting in the middle of the day
like can't we have something special
yeah if we're meeting in the middle of
the day for 30 minutes and like you know
it's our lunch break from work it's it's
not special and it's like what just so I
can get a look at to say yay or nay I
feel like that's like very serial dating
yeah yeah it's like speed dating almost
yes and I I don't think that's the way
to be even though I do think you should
go on a lot of dates if you're looking
for a partner but like not like that
yeah ice cream dates cute but even
though it feels like a second half of a
date not you know yeah it's like but I
don't know strolling around a small town
with an ice cream cone sitting on a
bench that's cute actually that's that's
a good like lowbudget date and also and
I don't mean low budget in a negative
way I mean like if you're going on a lot
of dates you don't have to spend $100
every dinner but that's because you
added the stroll if they were just
sitting in the ice cream shop eating
their ice cream and then going home it's
not enough no but there are definitely
ways to do dating on a budget and I
think you know walking around a park at
Twilight getting ice cream sitting like
that's cute yeah walking yeah with like
a little food truck maybe yeah yeah yeah
or ice cream truck yeah exactly next
family functions agreed no agreed uh
next movie night Netflix Hulu agreed no
cuz that also you have to be at their
house in a house next somewhere that
requires a long drive agreed no yep uh
next
bowling I think bowling is okay it's
like a fun activity to get to know
someone they sell liquor there yeah yeah
I think it's I actually I thought that
was going to be on the list and I would
disagree with it can you bul just two
people yeah it's just not as fun no next
nightclub agreed agreed next next hookah
bar agreed agreed next a bar for just
drinks disagree totally fine next Waffle
House no next sports events it's kind of
like a movie yeah it's better I think
it's okay I think it's okay that's kind
of nice if someone takes you to a sports
event they like care if both people are
really into sports yeah it's a common
ground to connect on yeah and it's like
that was a good story yeah I thought it
would spark some interesting
combo that's our show nice long one
today and I feel so good about it this
was like one of our best shows the Bell
thing I'm cracking up the
Bell b l l e cracking up so that's our
show thank you guys so much for
listening thank you guys for listening
to the CH Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching us on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
that's
spif box all the places you listen
podcast find toast five star view bet
have beautiful stunning and wicked lat
tality Ed we are have a great day love
you bye